Black Panther was directed by Ryan
Coogler and stars chadwick boseman and
Michael B Jordan and an amazing cast of
characters and tells the story of
T'Challa played by Bozeman who is about
to be crowned king of Wakanda a secret
city in the middle of Africa that's
completely shielded that's thriving and
yet no one knows about his existence and
what it first seemed like a
responsibility he could easily step into
he eventually learns there's a lot of
hardships with being a king of this
nation and a lot of problems arise when
his kingship is challenged by kill
monger I was excited for Black Panther
for a lot of reasons but specifically
because Kubler directed it I really
liked Fruitvale station and I thought
Creed was one of the best films of the
past few years for a seventh film and a
franchise to be that good and the fact
that Ryan Coogler is basically my age is
hugely inspirational to young filmmakers
out there it's so cool that someone who
is my age has already done what he's
done in Hollywood his future is so
bright and he proves that he is once
again a very good director with this
film he's three for three now Black
Panther is a really good time I had a
blast with it however I do not think it
is a flawless film and we're gonna talk
about some of the issues I have with the
movie that being said there's a lot to
praise and I'm very excited about the
fact that this film did not just make
another superhero movie Marvel didn't
just take this material and say okay
we're gonna make a movie where some
people fight and stuff blows up there's
a message behind this film and one
that's very relevant the best Marvel
movies thus far have all been like that
for instance Winter Soldier is not just
about Captain America fighting the
Winter Soldier it's about war it's about
the differences between freedom and fear
and what the implications of that could
mean for humankind which is one of the
reasons Black Panther stands out as
special because this is also not a movie
about characters just fighting it's a
film that has very relevant social
commentary sure there's a lot of action
sequences and stuff goes boom and
there's cool costumes and gadgets but I
also don't like when a film preaches to
me I don't want to go to a movie and
necessarily be taught a lesson that the
film assumes I didn't already know which
is why I was so relieved
find out that this film's commentary
relies on the characters in it
looking inside themselves the characters
in this film are really thinking about
their viewpoints and what was wrong
about their lives or their nation before
T'Challa took the crown because almost
all of T'Challa x' development relies on
him realizing the sins of the previous
generation and how he can make them
better it's not just about walking into
this perfect nation where his kingship
is unchallenged and everything was
thriving and amazing it's actually about
how damaging his previous generation was
and all of the problems that came from
that this is not something I expected
and by far my favorite aspect of this
movie is how these characters eventually
get to the point where they are looking
at themselves and trying to figure out
how they can make their lives and their
friendships and the world better as a
result and a lot of that has to do with
this film's villain it's one of the
reasons why Michael B Jordan character
kill monger is so damn good because his
appearance in this universe is what
starts this needed change for this
nation and although he's a villain and
he's doing things like killing innocent
people and you look at him and you think
no I don't agree with that you can
almost side with kill mongers beliefs
because you understand where he's coming
from he's someone who wasn't raised in
this protected shielded environment that
is Wakanda he was raised in the United
States he dealt with all of these
problems as a youth and now as an adult
he's standing there like hey you guys
have all of this technology why aren't
you sharing why aren't you helping
everyone else and these characters have
to stand back and think about that and
that's one of the reasons why kill
monger is such a great villain beyond
the fact that Michael B Jordan gives a
charismatic performance that's one of my
favorite Marvel villains thus far and
the best since Loki the reason his
villain is so good is because just like
all great movie villains their
appearance in the film is what causes
the heroes to look within themselves and
realize their weaknesses the worst
villains in films are the ones that are
just they're evil guys and you got to
stop
because they're gonna blow up the world
kill monger is not like that he's the
type of person who comes on the scene
and it's like I have these beliefs and I
hope you all understand that they're
totally relevant I might be kind of evil
and I might be killing innocent people
but listen to what I have to say and
they do and it's one of the reasons why
kill monger is such a great villain so
beyond the thematic issues that are
prevalent in Black Panther I also like a
lot of the behind the scenes stuff
Kubler once again enlists the same
composer from Creed who makes a
fantastic score I loved in particular
the percussion the color in this movie
is vibrant everyone the city of Wakanda
has amazing costumes
it's a gorgeously shot movie it looks
incredible and once T'Challa starts to
look within himself and realize the
change that has to happen I thought
Bozeman did a really great job leading
up until that he's a very kingly
presence he purposely does not have a
lot of charisma necessarily although he
is really great in this role the
character of T'Challa is one of the most
intelligent in the Marvel Universe and
he carries himself that way he's not an
asshole he's not some cocky a knowing
guy likes a Doctor Strange or Tony Stark
he's an extremely intelligent person and
that can make some of those earlier
scenes with him feel a little bit dull
because you're waiting for him to
realize some things because from the
very beginning of the movie you
recognize that eventually some
development is going to occur within
this world and once it starts to occur
the film becomes very interesting
leading up until that development though
the film does feel unfortunately a
little bit like your normal superhero
movie which was something that was a
disappointment for me
yeah I do have some flaws with Black
Panther and we're going to get into some
of those now this film is surrounded by
an almost impenetrable hype to the point
where people who say anything negative
about the movie it's almost like a crime
the very few rotten reviews that are on
Rotten Tomatoes ended up trending on
Twitter which is just crazy but I'm
someone who reviews movies and naturally
I'm going to try to do my best to be
realistic about that this film has
issues it felt like instead of hitting
us right off the bat with some of the
deeper issues in the film they made a
normal superhero movie for
while to get everyone else sort of into
it which was disappointing
I wanted this type of stuff from the
beginning yes the opening scene is
awesome and from the beginning I was
pretty riveted but then it becomes a
Marvel movie for a while there's a chase
scene involving SUVs that's well done
enough but it just sort of feels
inconsequential there's a lot of action
scenes that are a little bit too dark
and not quite as fluid as I was
expecting from a director who made one
of my favorite fight scenes in recent
years in Creede that one take boxing
match but there is a point in this movie
where the film absolutely changes and
becomes a much more interesting film and
it's right around when kill monger rears
his head once again towards the middle
also that was a disappointment I had he
shows up in the beginning in a really
cool scene and I was instantly hooked
with his character and then he's gone I
mean I've only seen it once but I would
say he was gone from maybe 50 minutes to
an hour almost and I was like where the
hell did he go when he shows up I was
almost like oh I forgot I was in the
film I loved his villain so much this
movie needed a lot more of it there were
also some CG elements that looked
unfinished there's a shot early on when
T'Challa is about to receive his crown
and he looks up at a clip side that is
filled with people of various tribes of
Wakanda and they almost look like copy
and pasted elements that were just put
on the frame it looked unfinished and if
it was just that one shot I would have
been like okay whatever but they show
this cliff side many more times and each
time I kept thinking that doesn't look
real there's a climactic fight towards
the end that begins with a shot that
looked like it was right out of
spider-man 3 with the two characters
falling down tumbling over each other in
the sky and then they fight in a very
dark cavernous area and they have very
dark suits on and it was hard to see
what was going on and looked like a lot
of CG this was a major disappointment of
a final fight for me a lot of people
will probably be fine with it but
pushing that aside what's really
honestly amazing about this film is that
looking back on it I am not thinking
about the action like I do with some
Marvel movies I'm not thinking about all
of the
cool epic moments I'm thinking about the
things that shape these characters into
who they become the things that affected
them the aspects of their life that
caused them to have the beliefs they
have so I have to commend Black Panther
because it stands out as a superhero
film where I'm not thinking the most
about all of the superhero stuff I'm
thinking about the characters I'm gonna
give Black Panther a B+ I'm buying the
blu-ray I'm gonna see the movie again in
theaters but it's not a film without
flaws and I think it's important that we
are able to discuss those flaws without
fearing repercussions because the hype
as I said surrounding this movie is
impenetrable it's almost like it's wrong
to say anything bad about it but in the
end it is a movie made by people and
it's got a few issues but I really
enjoyed myself and I think most people
will too guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]